les vitality sont des stars du jeu vidéo
avec des dizaines de milliers de fans
sur internet des maillots rempli de gros
sponsors et même des placements de
produits devant les caméras tout de
suite le vitality kirchen qui ont
peut-être pouvoir a attrapé l'espagne
leur spécialité le jeu de tir call of
duty ghost
c'étaient les grands favoris de la
finale la gamers assembly ils n'ont pas
tremblé
on a fait un mois qu'on voulait on a
bien joué ce week-end aucune frayeur
face à eux ce soir là une équipe
d'amateurs les tigers
c'est a dû rappeler des souvenirs aux
vitality quand ce n'était qu'une équipe
de potes
il était alors loin d'imaginer qu'ils
auraient un jour un manager chez m bravo
vraiment sûr on va dire la cohésion
d'équipé le fait de faire des efforts
les efforts ensemble
des fois ça passe vraiment par des
moments où il ya des creux il faut
essayer justement de
haranguer les troupes les vitality je
vous donc dans la cour des grands
devraient tireurs d'élite de l'industrie
vidéoludique
aujourd'hui c'est notre métier plus ou
moins il faut rester professionnel
sous-estiment pas du tout nos
adversaires et franchement on va tout
donner
le butin du jour un chèque de 3000 euros
une prise de guerre de plus pour ces
chasseurs de primes du jeu vidéo entre
deux tournois en europe ou à los angeles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]